>> ALRIGHT, SO I'M FAMILIAR WITH
SOME OF THE DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION THAT YOU'VE HAD
PUBLICLY.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU LOVE
ABOUT EACH OTHER.
SO WHY DON'T YOU TWO READ YOUR
LIST.
GEORGE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO START?
>> OKAY.
>> GO AHEAD, BABE.
>> WHAT I LOVE ABOUT KELLYANNE,
>> SHE WORKS SO HARD FOR HER
BOSS EVEN THOUGH I HATE HIS
GUTS.
>> I LIED.
THE CHILDREN ARE NOT DRINKING
FROM TOILETS.
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY DID NOT --
>> KELLYANNE, WE ARE OUT OF
TIME.
>> THEY CAN USE THE CORNER.
>> SOMETIMES SHE EVEN TALKS FOR
TOO LONG.
>> WHAT I LOVE ABOUT GEORGE, HE
ALWAYS LEAVES HIS COFFEE MUGS
AROUND.
HE ACTUALLY ALWAYS TELLS ME WHAT
HE THINKS ABOUT ME TO MY FACE.
>> GEORGE?
GEORGE, ARE YOU MAD AT ME?
>> OH, NO, NO, NO.
>> GEORGE?
AM I DEMON?
>> OH, FROM WHAT?
I CAN'T TELL.
I DON'T EVEN -- I CAN'T SEE IN
HERE.
IT'S KIND OF DARK AND LOUD.
I THINK I'M GOING THROUGH A
TUNNEL.
>> GEORGE CONWAY.
DO NOT SUBTWEET ME AT THE DINNER
TABLE, PLEASE.
>> WE FIND WAYS TO SPEND TIME
TOGETHER.
>> OUR LITTLE PET NAMES.
>> WE FIND WAYS TO KEEP IN TOUCH
DURING THE WORKDAY.
>> I LOVE HOW MY BOSS CALLED HIM
A STONE-COLD LOSER AND HUSBAND
FROM HELL.
I'M SORRY, THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
GEORGE --
>> I LOVE THAT SHE'S A POET.
>> THIS IS THE TRUTH THAT THEY
DON'T WANT YOU TO KNOW.
I LOVE THAT HE LOVES TO READ THE
DSM TO FIND OUT WHAT'S WRONG MY
BOSS.
>> NARCISSIST, THERE IT IS.
I LOVE THAT WHEN ANN COULTER SET
US UP, SHE THOUGHT, THESE TWO
ARE PERFECT FOR EACH OTHER."
>> I LOVE THAT WE AGREE ON THE
BIG STUFF LIKE SMALL GOVERNMENT
AND NO FOOD FOR THE POOR.
>> GET A JOB.
>> AND I KNOW I'M NOT SUPPOSED
TO BUT I EVEN LOVE OUR FIGHTS.
>> I FEEL BAD FOR YOU.
>> YOU ARE THE ONE WHO
INTRODUCED US, GEORGE.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW HE'D BE
PRESIDENT.
>> YOU'RE NOT EVEN VERIFIED ON
TWITTER.
WHERE IS YOUR BLUE CHECK,
GEORGE?
>> -- HAS JUST ANNOUNCED
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> OKAY, SO DO YOU HAVE WHAT YOU
NEED FOR YOUR PIECE?
>> PIECE?
OH, I'M NOT A REPORTER.
I'M A THERAPIST.
>> OH, THIS ISN'T FOR A BOOK?
>> OH, NO.
WHAT YOU SAY DOESN'T LEAVE THIS
ROOM?
>> THEN WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
>> WE'RE GOING TO GO.
WE HAVE TO FIGHT ON "THE VIEW."
>> HON, I GOT TO BE DONE BY
5:00 FOR DINNER WITH
KATHY GRIFFIN.
>> DON'T GET ME ALL HOT.